a vida
qual é o valor da nossa vila que fazemos
com nossa vila
para mim é tão valioso como o meu
próprio percurso de vida
a entrega da minha existência
a visitação absoluta à luz daquilo que
existe mais extraordinária mente
apaixonante do universo
hoje sou verdadeiramente apaixonada por
pessoas à nossa complexidade da nossa
capacidade única de conciliar dois
sistemas de processamento de 20 final
nacional extraordinário
nós conseguimos sentir e pensar em
simultâneo sobre a mesma partícula que
nos envolve
ao longo destes anos não para nos
surpreender com nossa capacidade de nos
adaptarmos de enfrentar os os nossos
problemas e é exatamente nos momentos
mais adversos que nós conseguimos ser
mais capaz de nos adaptar nos
enfrentarmos esta que é possível montar
os nossos primário sem osso enquanto
almoçava bens enquanto passávamos mamute
ou fora dos cassados por eles mas
certamente seria um ambiente adverso e
nós sobrevivemos nós evoluímos
nós somos capazes de resistir a guerras
a catástrofe é que tons e resistimos e
adaptamos enfrentamos e mesmo a nossa
esfera mais pessoal
somos capazes de enfrentar exigências
como a perda dos norte enfrentará morta
quem nos vê quem vive no nosso coração
que nos é próximo e almas amputá las
nós somos capazes em paralelo com esta
nossa capacidade com este impulso
sobrevivência viva
existe um avo mais negro da nossa mente
o impulso pela morte
já quando você já pensou na sua morte
foi um desafio quem já pensou em
terminar com a sua própria vida tem a
coragem de colocar a mão no ar
os números são importantes na nossa vida
uma pessoa suicidas aquela 40 as fontes
em alguma parte do mundo
o suicídio a uma das causas de morte
mais prevalentes em todo mundo
nós vivemos numa cilada complexa célula
que nos encontros a obrigação de não
falhar nos servir de faith e procuramos
respostas respostas que nos permitam
estar seguros protegidos nos faça sentir
integrados que nos dê resposta para
enfrentarmos as nossas exigências da
viva que nos permitam enfrentar nossos
demônios os nossos problemas
compreender o que nos vai a e controlar
o mundo sim tem uma novidade
nós somos controladores em nossa
essência
ainda assim a nossa mente
subsiste como um mistério
enquanto é combinada entre o sinal
comunidade científica se empenha em
procurar resposta em procurar a cura
para a doença junto tais em dilatar a
nossa esperança de vida o número de
pessoas viva os seus dias dominado por
pensamentos de morte vive o seu dia a
dia
controlado pela eleição de terminar com
a sua própria vida
e viva os seus pensamentos camuflados
o aparente normalidade dos seus habitats
que todos esperam que tenha habilidade
social
nós sabemos que esperam de nós ou
porventura apenas gêmeos aquilo que
queremos ver
talvez seja mais fácil para nós ver
aquilo que nos causa menos sofrimento
feira que o potencial pessoal não
queremos perceber não queremos
identificar
não queremos detectar os sinais e os
pensamentos de morte existem estão à
nossa volta
estão nos conhecidos nos amigos da
família em nosso
estudos mostram que em algum momento das
nossas vidas
pensamos na morte como uma possibilidade
como uma saída para a nossa problema
porém no uso da nossa faculdade mental e
com equilíbrio no final somos capazes de
ter uma postura crítica e procurar
outras alternativas - nós - inclusivas
para nós e para as finais
esta é uma constatação
vivemos lá do lado com o sofrimento
humano é uma realidade que não aprovaria
e por vezes a morte é uma porta para um
mundo que crê sem sofrimento
nós profissionais de emergência
transformamos muitas vezes esta parede
esta barreira destas vidas camufladas
encontramos vidas nas mãos dadas
despojados daquilo que socialmente é o
correto e encontramos a vida tal qual é
nos dias de hoje em que por vez
é tão angustiantes apesar da nossa vida
quando enfrentarmos a morte
ao longo destes anos jean em que entrar
nestas vidas nos largos das pessoas
sendo uma delas ficou tatuava na memória
cada uma delas com sua particularidade
com algo único e irrepetível que deixou
aqui também em mim na minha vida
profissional e na minha vida pessoal
poderíamos contar para criar inúmeras
histórias
o antônio 41 anos com emprego estável
o seu filho de 12 anos a esposa tinha
sido quatro anos antes foi encontrado
seu filho sem vida no chão da cozinha
a causa da morte
ao transformar a barreira à porta desta
residência encontramos um caos
a desorganização era difícil caminhar
mas receber pronto nos deslocarmos
porque sempre há vão
restos de comida roupa juichi e esta
habitação deste núcleo no seio da
sociedade abundância mas em simultâneo
da organização o caucho sofrimento
o manoel 43 anos desempregada vivia
sozinho desde do seu divórcio e
religiosamente tenha uma rotina e ficar
a sua filha à escola filha de 12 anos e
acompanhá la até a casa da mãe onde ela
vivia passando pelo café um dos santos
reúne com seus amigos um dia não não
comprei esta feira não apareceu foi
encontrado em casa
enforcado a descrição deste espaço
resume se a um corpo pendurado em uma
casa era uma velha e não era onde
estavam as cinzas o vazio dilacerante
as duas histórias têm em comum o
isolamento social
o sofrimento solitário é ainda que não
saiu no maio uma comunidade no celular
das duas pessoas no sofrimento invisível
os sinais provavelmente não foram
detetados e na atenção nestes finais
quem será mais perspicaz afetá-los
crianças
outro desafio quem considera que serão
os adultos mais perspicaz na obtenção
sinais de perturbação da alteração do
comportamento foi o coloca no ar
temos uma sala unânime
as crianças
a joana
a joana 15 anos vivia com seus pais e
sua irmã de 9 anos aluna scholante os
seus dias preferidos em que elas flores
eram passadas em casa juntamente com
seus pais e com sua irmã
certo dia foi encontrada pelo pai num
anexo da sua garagem sem villa tinha
fechado a porta por dentro dessa desse
elenco e capô a cavar prancha pronto
poderia circular novamente teimou papéis
e colocou sua cabeça morreu então shica
os pais
enfrentando uma situação inopinada sem
qualquer previsão que pudesse acontecer
não detetaram um mini no final não
percebeu encontraram nenhum sinal de que
algo poderia estar a passar se com joana
sua vez a irmã dizia sabe que anima e
minha mãe queria morrer ela tenha
comportamentos estranhos
ela dizia que as pessoas como eu não
tenho tanta sorte
por isso
as crianças são mais perspicaz não fazem
a abstração que nós fazemos da realidade
queremos o que não queremos ver absorvem
a informação
vemos crianças enfrentar o mundo entre o
portal saem temor daquilo que vamos
encontrar enigmas pensamentos sobre tudo
isto e valem certamente a vossa mente
será que já nesta situação será que a
encontrei alguém já tem alguém nesta
situação que eu poderei fazer como é que
eu posso ajudar como eu posso ajudar
alguém esta turbilhão neste calendário
copco fim dos sonhos e pensamentos
deixo-vos 50 acho que na caixa do
primeiro corte nestas situações a escuta
é base da nossa evolução enquanto seres
humanos e comunicação e escuta não é
apenas um álbum caniche biológico de
ouvirmos recebemos sons e darmos tempo
dar mais atenção à luta
aqui nós temos connosco se ver e rever o
conteúdo mas também a forma como esse
efeito é entrega a outro
a expressão ensinar os sentimentos
relacionados com suicídios são em tensos
pressão muito forte e precisam ser
preste a nossa sociedade muitas vezes
amputa esta possibilidade nós nos
apressamos nós mostrarmos nossas opções
de chorar é tão importante chorar é tão
importante mostrarmos nossas invenções
sintonia conosco por um simples aliviar
e descomprimir da nossa tensão emocional
no funeral do seu pai
uma criança de 11 anos chorava
copiosamente e aferimento todas as
pessoas muito preocupadas porque o choro
porque não estava conseguindo controlar
o choro aquela criança ia chorar diz é
tão importante mostrar a profunda
tristeza que o momento em vale aquela
criança
permite-nos funcionário estava arrasado
e chora e nós temos capazes de estar
presente
não viramos as costas porque não sabemos
o que fazer
chay empatia é nossa capacidade de
percebermos o outro é capaz irá vamos
colocar no seu lugar não é sentir o
mesmo mas sem calçar os sapatos quando
desenho chinesa
sim com carlos no lugar avião e
imaginários como tentamos compreender
como se poderá estar a sentir naquela
situação
nós temos essa que eu passei lá não é
ser simpático seu evento encerrou
mas naquele momento tentar entender
aquela pessoa genuinamente é irrigação o
pensamento ea intenção dos níveis de
2010 portanto numa situação em que uma
pessoa revela que está em pensamentos de
morte fazer essa distinção porque a
aviação é um pensamento que surge que é
importante ser tentado mas que nós
podemos ter capacidade de criticar nós
podemos ter capacidade de entender as
suas conseqüências
sua vez é intenção é um nível maior
gravidade porque significa que a pessoa
tomou uma decisão em sohar todos os
guaranis é uma situação para dar atenção
e para orientarmos para ajudarmos não
mais devemos deixar de atender aquela
pessoa por vez pode por ser difícil
fazermos essa extensão
mas o discurso é
frente e conquistando assim a quinta
âncora que alternativas ajudarmos a
pessoa a encontrar alternativas sem
julgar suicida é correto ou incorreto
para mim faz sentido não faz sentido
então importa para aquela pessoa importa
tentarmos ajudar a encontrar outras
alternativas
é esta que é uma resolução
quando a pessoa não tem mais capacidade
para suportar o seu próprio sofrimento
quando o sofrimento supõe a sua
capacidade de ajudar a pessoa a
encontrar alternativas pode passar por
exemplo por demonstrar que exista ajuda
profissional é uma alternativa
desde que subi a este palco neste
momento num telex ao porto
mais de 20 pessoas se suicidaram
esta é minha paixão
a solução para o sofrimento individual
está nas relações humanas
eu estou presente nos momentos de
fragilidade consigo tocar a fragilidade
humana em momentos críticos da sua
existência das suas vivas mas procura
ajudá las
procuro estar presente e orientá-las
izar mim para que encontrem seus
recursos para que recuperem o seu
equilíbrio emocional e racional